WAY
♪ EVERY DAY
>> Jesse: TEAM TRUMP GOINGEN
OFFICE IN THE URK
WHISTLEBLOWER CONTROVERSY.
HAMMERING JOE BIDEN AND
ACCUSING HIM OF LYING WHILE
THE FORMER V.P. IS FIRING
BACK.
>> WHAT BIDEN DID IS A
DISGRACE.
WHAT HIS SON DID IS A
THE SON TOOK MONEY FROM URK
UKRAINE.
THE SON TOOK A LOT OF MONEY
FROM CHINA.
CHINA WOULD LOVE TO SEE.
THEY CAN THINK OF NOTHING
THEY WOULD RATHER SEE THAN
BIDEN GET.
IN WHAT BIDEN DID WAS WRONG.
>> YOU SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
TRUMP.
TRUMP'S DOING THIS BECAUSE
HE KNOWS I WILL BEAT HIM
LIKE A DRUM.
HE IS USING THE ABUSE OF
POWER AND EVERY ELEMENT OF
THE PRESIDENCY TO TRY TO DO
SOMETHING TO SMEAR ME.
>> Jesse: OKAY.
DEMOCRATS PREDICTABLY
SEIZING ON THE STORY EVEN
THOUGH THEY DON'T HAVE ALL
THE FACTS.
FOR EXAMPLE, SOURCES TELLING
FOX NEWS THE WHISTLEBLOWER
DOESN'T EVEN HAVE, QUOTE:
FIRSTHAND KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT
TRUMP SAID TO THE PRESIDENT
OF UKRAINE.
THAT OF COURSE, IS NOT
STOPPING CALLS FOR TRUMP'S
IMPEACHMENT.
>> IT IS TIME FOR US TO CALL
OUT THIS ILLEGAL BEHAVIOR
AND START IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS RIGHT NOW.
>> SO OF COURSE IT'S AN
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
>> THERE IS NO WAY TO DEFEND
THE LACK OF PROGRESS ON
IMPEACHMENT, ESPECIALLY
AFTER WHAT WE HAVE JUST
LEARNED.
>> WE NEED TO ABSOLUTELY,
RIGHT AWAY, BEGIN
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS.
HE HAS GOT TO GO.
>> IF THE PRESIDENT IS
ESSENTIALLY WITHHOLDING
MILITARY AID AT THE SAME
TIME THAT HE IS TRYING TO
BROWBEAT A FOREIGN LEADER
INTO DOING SOMETHING ILLICIT
THAT IS PROVIDING DIRT ON
HIS OPPONENT DURING A
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN, THEN
THAT MAY BE THE ONLY REMEDY.
>> Jesse: WHILE THE MAJORITY
OF THE MEDIA IS YOU FOCUSING
ON TRUMP'S ROLE IN IN THIS
NEW YORKER ARTICLE GETTING
NEW ATTENTION THAT POINTS
THE FINGER AT THE DEMOCRATIC
FRONTRUNNER ASKING, QUOTE:
WILL HUNTER BIDEN JEOPARDIZE
HIS FATHER'S CAMPAIGN?
IN THAT ARTICLE, JUAN, THEY
REPORT THAT ALTHOUGH THAT
JOE BIDEN SAID OH, I NEVER
TALKED ABOUT ANY SORT OF
INTERNATIONAL BUSINESS
DEALINGS WITH MY SON.
HUNTER SAYS OH, YEAH, WE
TALKED ABOUT IT.
IT DOESN'T LOOK TOO GOOD,
DOES IT.
>> Juan: I THINK IT DOESN'T
LOOK TOO GOOD FOR TRUMP.
>> Jesse: WHY?
>> Juan: EVERYBODY HAS
INVESTIGATED.
THIS IS NOT NEW ABOUT HUNTER
BIDEN AND HIS DAD TRUMP
CALLING HIM A DRUG -- I
DIDN'T LIKE THAT.
THE WHOLE THING IS JUST
TRUMP HAS A STYLE.
WHICH IS HE GOES ON THE
OFFENSIVE WHEN HE IS UNDER
ATTACK.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE SEE.
I THINK JOE BIDEN IS RIGHT.
JOE BIDEN SEES THAT HE IS
THE TARGET OF TRUMP'S IRE
BECAUSE TRUMP SEES IN EVERY
POLL BIDEN COULD BEAT HIM
LIKE A DRUM.
TO ME I HOPE EVERYONE ON
THIS TABLE CAN AGREE ON
THIS.
THE WHITE HOUSE SHOULD
RELEASE THE TRANSCRIPTS.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THE LAW
REQUIRES.
IT'S NOT A MATTER OF
ARGUMENT.
>> Jesse: NO, IT DOESN'T.
>> Juan: IT SAYS IF THE IG,
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL FOR
THE DIRECTOR OF FLASH
INTELLIGENCE DEEMS THIS AN
URGENT CONCERN IT SHOULD GO
TO THE CONGRESS.
>> Jesse: IT WASN'T DEEMED
AN URGENT CONCERN.
>> Juan: IT WAS.
>> Jesse: I HAVE U.S. CODE
5033 K SAY IT DIDN'T RISE TO
THE LEVEL OF URGENT.
WHY DON'T WE DECLASSIFY
EVERYTHING?
A PRESIDENT CAN'T HAVE ANY
CONVERSATION WITH A FOREIGN
LEADER.
HE WILL JUST RELEASE THE
TRANSCRIPT TO THE PUBLIC AND
YOU KNOW WHILE WE ARE AT IT
LET'S DECLASSIFY THE FISA
REPORTS.
HEY, NOTHING WAS UNTOWARD
THERE.
RIGHT, JUAN?
IT DOESN'T GO THAT WAY.
>> Juan: BARACK OBAMA TRIED
TO USE U.S. MONEY TO TRY TO
EXTORT A FOREIGN POWER.
>> Jesse: JOE BIDEN JUST
DID.
>> Juan: NO.
>> Jesse: ROLL THE TAPE.
ROLL IT.
THAT.
>> WE ARE NOT GOING TO GIVE
YOU THE BILLION DOLLARS.
THEY SAID HAVE YOU NO
AUTHORITY.
YOU ARE NOT THE PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT SAID I SAID
CALL HIM.
[LAUGHTER]
I SAID I'M TELLING YOU, YOU
ARE NOT GETTING A BILLION
DOLLARS.
I SAID YOU ARE NOT GETTING A
BILLION.
I'M GOING TO BE LEAVING HERE
AND I THINK IT WAS SIX
HOURS.
LEAVING HERE IN SIX HOURS
AND THE PROSECUTOR IS NOT
FIRED, YOU ARE NOT GETTING
THE MONEY.
WELL SON OF A [BLEEP]
[LAUGHTER]
HE GOT FIRED.
>> Jesse: YEAH, SO HE SAID
FIRE THE PROSECUTOR
INVESTIGATING MY SON OR ELSE
YOU ARE NOT GETTING A
BILLION.
>> Greg: HE ALSO SAID THAT
HE NEVER SPOKE TO HIS SON
ABOUT THIS WHICH YOU KNOW IS
NOT TRUE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS A RIGHT TO
TALK ABOUT ANY PROBLEM.
WHO DEFINES THIS IS WRONG?
HE IS JUST PURSUING A
QUESTION.
YOU KNOW, THE MEDIA SHOULD
BE HAPPY THAT HE IS TRYING
TO INVESTIGATE A POSSIBLE
INFRACTION.
THEY SHOULD BE APPLAUDING.
BUT YOU KNOW THIS IS
REACHING PURE PARODY WHEN
CNN TROTZ OUT KARL BERNSTEIN
TO SAY FOR THE 400TH TIME
THIS IS WORSE THAN
WATERGATE.
YOU KNOW IT'S FALLING APART.
IMAGINE LEADING WITH KARL
BERNSTEIN THE FOOD ARRIVES
LATE AT THE RESTAURANT THIS
IS WORSE THAN WATERGATE.
HIS iPHONE CHARGER ISN'T
WORKING THIS IS WORSE THAN
WATERGATE.
NO DAIRY CREAMER, THIS IS
WORSE THAN WATERGATE.
DOES HE GET ROYALTIES EVERY
TIME HE SAYS THAT?
THIS IS ONE OF THE SIGNS
FALLING APART.
THE MEDIA'S HAIR CATCHES ON
FIRE TOO EARLY.
WE GET SO JADE.
WE DON'T TRUST THEM ANYMORE.
I DON'T BELIEVE ANYTHING
ANYMORE.
>> Jesse: WHAT WAS THAT
CONVERSATION WITH MEDVEDEV
BARACK OBAMA CAUGHT ON THE
HOT MIC JUST GIVE ME MORE
FLEXIBILITY UNTIL AFTER THE
ELECTION AGAINST ROMNEY AND
HE SAYS YES, I WILL TRANSMIT
THAT TO VLADIMIR.
I WONDER WHAT THAT ISSUE
WAS.
NO INTEREST IN THAT.
>> Dana: BASICALLY THRUSTS
TO THE FOREFRONT TWO BASIC
ISSUES THAT THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE BEEN TRYING TO STAVE
OFF.
THE FIRST ONE IS PELOSI HAS
BEEN TRYING TO HOLD OFF HER
CAUCUS TO AND SAY WE DON'T
NEED -- SHE IS LIKE I'M NOT
FOR IMPEACHMENT.
SHE SENDS A LETTER THEN
YESTERDAY BECAUSE I DO THINK
THEY JUMPED THE GUN.
CAN YOU SAY IS THIS A GOOD
IDEA TO BE PRESSURING LIKE,
I DON'T KNOW.
OKAY, FINE.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS HE WANTS
TO RELEASE THE TRANSCRIPTS.
HE SAYS HE WANTS TO RELEASE
THE FISA DOCUMENTS, TOO.
SO HE HAS THE POWER TO DO
IT.
AND I'M NOT FOR RELEASING
THESE TYPES OF TRANSCRIPTS.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT.
IF IT'S GOING TO GO TO THIS
EXTENT RELEASE IT AND
EVERYBODY CAN HAVE THE
DEBATE ABOUT IT.
THE OTHER ONE THAT THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN TRYING
TO STAVE OFF IS THE QUESTION
ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN'S
BUSINESS DEALINGS.
THAT NEW YORKER ARTICLE RAN
LAST SPRING.
NOBODY REALLY PAID THAT MUCH
ATTENTION TO IT BECAUSE
BIDEN HADN'T ANNOUNCED YET.
AND NOW HE IS IN.
>> Emily: IT'S CLASSIC
DEFLECTION STRATEGY.
THIS IS WHAT ALWAYS HAPPENS.
ANY TIME ANYONE ON THE LEFT
DOES SOMETHING BAD.
WE GET A LEAK HOW AND WHY
THE PRESIDENT DID SOMETHING
WORSE BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS
DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
HUNTER BIDEN BEING ON THE
BOARD OF THE UKRAINIAN
COMPANY OR GETTING BANK
ROLLED BY CHINA OR HAVING
HIS DAD TALK ABOUT DEMANDING
THAT THE PROSECUTOR BE
FIRED.
ALL OF THOSE ARE HIDEOUS
SUBJECTS FOR THE LEFT.
AND YOU ARE RIGHT, THEY HAVE
BEEN AROUND FOR QUITE SOME
TIME.
THAT'S WHY IT'S SO
FRUSTRATING FOR THE G.O.P.
THE ONLY SILVER LINING TO
ALL OF, THIS HOWEVER, IS THE
NOW KIND OF REGROWN CLAMOR
BY SOME OF THEM, INCLUDING
AOC TO START THOSE IMEEMPLET
PROCEEDINGS BECAUSE IT'S
CALLING ATTENTION TO THE
CIVIL WAR.
>> Greg: THIS COULD BE A
DEMOCRATIC STRATEGY TO GET
BIDEN OUT.
>> Jesse: WE ARE HEARING
THAT HILLARY ACTUALLY WAS
BEHIND THE INITIAL HUNTER